my biggest training problem is over
training it's like the fear of not being
able to do enough in a short amount of
time you know like I'm in the prime of
my career I'm I'm still super young but
you know I realize that life is super
short and there are all those times you
gotta just like enjoy the little things
and just relax and um you know the kids
my one-year-old twin daughters
um you know have really taught me that
you know being able to just come like
all the way back down to the core of
what's important and just playing with
them you know on the carpet and like
just making stacking little blocks and
having them knock it over you know it's
like
it's so easy to get so wrapped up in you
know the career and the ideas and where
we want to go and how big we want to
become and it's like racing a car around
a circuit you know it's like you're not
pedal to the metal the whole time you
know you're lifting and you're pressing
and you got to know when to do that and
somebody who can dance the dance is
going to be able to get around the track
the fastest